ever since cars were invented people
have tried to make them fly some dreamed
of traveling from home to the office and
minutes others imagine flying vehicles
that didn't look anything like a car but
now the dream may be closer than ever to
reality developers have worked on it
quietly for nine years in a secret
Silicon Valley location only on CBS this
morning John Blackstone got a first look
at the airborne project Marquez Lane
calls his invention a personal aviation
vehicle an electric aircraft so easy to
fly he says you need little training and
no pilot's license when you press the
thumb stick to climb with this you have
absolute full control Lane gave CBS this
morning an exclusive tour of the secret
Silicon Valley facility where the craft
he calls black fly is being built his
breakthrough invention what we're gonna
do is we're just gonna run is a small
but extremely powerful electric motor
this can produce 100
[Music]
Lane claims the eight motor single-seat
aircraft has actually flown thousands of
miles in test flights controlled from
the ground before they ever put people
in the cockpit we first flew 10,000
miles we did a thousand plus flights all
autonomous autonomous and we had a
payload of 200 pounds so what are the
safety features first of all you have to
start off with the technology and some
magic buttons like a return to home
button for people who fly for the first
time for decades flying cars have been
part of a future that has never quite
arrived this was the commuter this would
have been the helicopter and everybody's
garage the Hiller Aviation Museum in
Silicon Valley displays several flying
cars that just didn't get off the ground
the technology wasn't there because
they'd have the computers and now the
computers can actually manipulate the
controls now companies around the world
are developing flying cars Google
co-founder Larry Page is supporting two
flying car projects uber is working on
flying taxis mark is laying wants black
fly to be on sale next year so anyone
can buy it we're talking price of a
luxury Mercedes price of an SUV
price of an SUV how long will it take to
learn to fly one of these you know in a
simulator in five minutes Alan Eustace
former vice president of knowledge at
Google is on black flies Board of
Directors and knows about flight he was
carried by balloon into the stratosphere
then parachuted nearly a hundred 36,000
feet breaking a world altitude record in
2014 he's almost as excited about black
fly and I've noticed in my career that
things go from impossible to inevitable
in a very short period of time it's no
longer technology standing in the way he
says but rather regulations governing
flight there's regulatory issues to deal
with but you know in theory right now
you could take this vehicle you could
put it out here you could fly to San
Francisco and you could be there and you
know
eight minutes under current federal
regulations black fly is classified as
an ultralight aircraft meaning it can't
fly at night or over urban areas it can
travel just 25 miles on its electric
batteries but the joy of flight seems
unlimited they're just incredibly fun to
fly instant gratification for CBS this
morning John Blackstone Palo Alto
California I'm excited about that
possibility I mean it's a sexy little
vehicle but I think the ground is
underrated no it's nice it's really
smooth you're in touch with you gravity
are you yeah exactly very in touch with
gravity seems like less traffic though
in the air you're right
all right we'll keep you posted on that
reality